how are you doing today sir I'm great
how are you the footage look fantastic
thanks dude so uh what can you actually
say about your
man I can't say anything at all my boss
is just right here but no sorry continue
so so you you can't say your character's
name I can't um
um I can tell you that you know he's
a citizen he's a a guy within this
galaxy who gets
um pulled into this larger Mission
within the high Republic and the Jedi
yeah so whether he likes it or not he's
kind of in this ride
um what has actually surprised you about
making this series that you did not
expect going in
the passion you know sometimes you take
a project and it's like okay we're gonna
do this cool thing but everyone from our
showrunners our directors our cast like
there's something at stake for all of us
um it's I think it's what makes our our
show so special it's because we have
something more to prove we have just
yeah we have more stake in it in the
sense that it's more tight emotionally
rather than just doing something fun
um what is it like on set when the
lightsaber is being wielded
well I don't really get to my extent of
playing with the lightsabers stealing
Daphne's or Charlie's lightsaber and
taking selfies in the washroom so I
don't really get to do that much
um but it's cool watching them work and
do their thing
um I'm always in awe especially if these
guys getting to yeah getting to do that
stuff a little jealous I'll talk to
Leslie again maybe maybe do do something
next season
um what uh what is actually what is what
have the scripts been like for you to
read Because ultimately that's where it
all comes from and I'm curious what do
you think what do you think fans are
going to be like most happy with when
the show comes out you see what I mean
like I'm trying to get a feel for tone
yeah like for whatever you can say
so Leslie is a true fan
she is almost like an encyclopedia of
Star Wars like she does the art she
cosplay she does the RPGs she's yeah
she's she's done a PhD in Star Wars so
when when you watch this show you'll
notice the little Easter eggs the the
little nods to the high Republic but
even the nods to like
um the original trilogy like you'll see
how we incorporate those within our show
um and Leslie is the only person that
can pull that off because she's such a
fan of this world I really can't wait
that footage downstairs looked awesome
oh thanks I really did on that note I'm
Gonna Let You Go do more speed dating
okay I'm just gonna say I can't wait to
talk about the series when it's done
thank you man